en el último vídeo vimos una forma de
determinar la acidez de las moléculas y
eso es simplemente mirando la
estabilidad de las bases con jugadas y
mientras más estable fuera la base con
jugada más ácida es la molécula y en ese
vídeo también hablamos acerca de la
electro negatividad que estabiliza la
base con jugada ahora en este vídeo
vamos a mirar nuevamente la electro
negatividad pero vamos a enfocarnos en
las estructuras resonantes y las
estructuras resonantes nos permitirán o
van a permitirle a la estabilización la
estabilidad perdón de la base con jugada
así que vamos a empezar con el propano
que tenemos aquí y si pensamos en el
valor pk de este protón digamos de este
de aquí simplemente vamos a obtener un
resultado aproximadamente de 50 así que
el propano no es muy ácido del todo pero
si pensamos en el propano que va a donar
un protón entonces estos electrones
verdad van a pasar
a formar bueno van a pasar de este lado
con el carbono así que vamos a dibujar
nuestra base con jugada que obtenemos
tenemos simplemente la misma estructura
digamos de este lado exactamente igual a
este carbono le tocan dos hidrógenos
verdad y a éste lo vamos a unir con este
último carbono que va a estar unido a
estos dos hidrógenos pero ahora estos
dos electrones van a estar aquí pasando
verdad ya que el el este hidrógeno o
este protón fue cedido entonces
obtenemos una carga negativa una carga
formal negativa y por lo tanto tenemos
un carbón
verdad así que en este carbón la carga
se localiza en este átomo de carbono y
dado que el carbono no es muy electrón
negativo no se estabiliza
no estabiliza la carga negativa muy bien
así que esta es una razón por la cual es
una base con jugada inestable verdad
otras razones que no puedes dibujar una
estructura resonante para esta base con
jugada y no puedes dispersar esta esta
carga negativa
a lo largo de la molécula para
deslocalizar estos electrones y
estabilizar la base con jugada así que
por estas dos razones tenemos una base
con jugada inestable y dado que tenemos
una base con jugada inestable esa es la
razón por la cual el propano no es muy
ácido y tiene un valor pk extremadamente
alto así que ahora vamos a compararlo
vamos a comparar este propano con el
propano que es esta molécula que tenemos
aquí así que si si miramos digamos cual
no sé por ejemplo tomamos este protón si
nos fijamos en ese protón el valor pk de
este protón es aproximadamente de 43 así
que el propano es más ácido que el
propano y podemos explicar esto
simplemente mirando la base
con jugada y que vamos a dibujar en unos
momentos simplemente vamos a tener este
carbono doble enlace con el carbono y
con este otro carbono muy bien a éste le
corresponden tres hidrógenos verdad
simplemente a éste le corresponde un
hidrógeno y a éste le corresponden sólo
dos sólo dos hidrógenos y estos
electrones de este de este enlace pasan
a formar parte del carbono entonces
vamos a tener estos dos electrones
verdad así que nuevamente tenemos una
carga negativa en un átomo que no es muy
electro negativo y ese es un factor por
la cual uno podría creer que no es una
base con jugada muy estable verdad sin
embargo podemos dibujar una estructura
de resonancia para esta base con jugada
así que vamos a poner una base vamos a
poner una una flecha digamos que indique
resonancia aunque y vamos a dibujarlo y
qué es lo que tenemos pues una una una
estructura resonante sería la siguiente
este enlace de aquí este uno de los
enlaces dobles pasaría a ser parte de
unos electrones del carbono mientras que
digamos estos electrones que estoy
pintando con morado pasarían a ser parte
de un enlace nuevo verdad entonces la
estructura digamos resonante que voy a
dibujar es la siguiente vamos a tener
este carbono unido con sus hidrógenos
sus hidrógenos pero ahora este enlace
azul va a ser un par de electrones
verdad de genet déjenme pintarlo
ahí lo tienen entonces ahora tendríamos
aquí este hidrógeno y este enlace va aa
ser un par de electrones que van a estar
en este carbono y que por lo tanto le
van a dar una carga negativa a este
carbono verdad ahora nos queda un enlace
unido a este carbono este hidrógeno y
ahora tenemos dos electrones que pasan a
ser parte de un enlace van a formar un
enlace y con el otro enlace que ya
tenemos que ya teníamos se forma un
enlace doble verdad entonces aquí
simplemente completamos con los dos
hidrógenos y ahí tenemos una estructura
resonante para esta base conjugada y
bueno sólo hay que recordar que la base
conjugada real sería un híbrido de estas
dos estructuras resonantes pero la carga
negativa lo importante es que se puede
dispersar a lo largo de esta molécula
simplemente no está localizada en un
único carbono tenemos dos posibles y se
dispersa y más bien se deslocaliza a
través de esta molécula y eso es lo que
le da estabilidad a esta carga negativa
hace que la base conjugada sea más
estable y como la base conjugar es más
estable esa es la razón por la cual el
propano
es más ácido que el propano ahora vamos
a comparar el propano con el etanol que
íbamos a comprar con el etanol que es
esta molécula de aquí ahí lo tienen y ya
la hemos visto en los dos vídeos
anteriores me parece verdad simplemente
el protón ha sido digamos es este y
sabemos que el valor pecado del etanol
es de aproximadamente 16 entonces
podemos ver que efectivamente es más
ácido que los dos ejemplos anteriores y
nuevamente vamos a tratar de explicarlo
a través de nuestra nuestra base
conjugada verdad tendríamos este carbono
unido a este carbono unido a este
oxígeno y que es lo que va a pasar que
este enlace va a ser se va a pasar a
hacer 2 electrones solitarios que van a
estar alrededor del oxígeno verdad
entonces aquí tendremos estos tres
enlaces
estos tres hidrógenos a este le
corresponden dos hidrógenos dos
hidrógenos y al oxígeno le corresponden
sus cuatro electrones que ya tenía más
otros dos que obtiene al separar este
protón de la molécula verdad entonces
ahí tenemos nuestra base conjugada y
podemos ver que en realidad esta base
conjugada no puede no tiene una
estructura resonante entonces toda la
explicación de por qué es ácido la
estabilidad de esta base conjugada es
simplemente porque el oxígeno es más
electro negativo verdad
a diferencia del ejemplo anterior en
donde la carga negativa se localizaba en
un átomo de carbono en este caso se
localiza en un oxígeno y como es más
electro negativo eso le da más
estabilidad a esta base conjugada y por
lo tanto eso hace que el etanol sea
mucho mucho más ácido verdad entonces
esta es la explicación de por qué es más
ácido verdad entonces resulta que la
idea de la electro negatividad o de un
átomo electro negativo resulta ser más
importante que la idea de la resonancia
así que la electro negatividad es más
importante que la resonancia ahora vamos
a comparar el etanol con el ácido
acético ahí tenemos el ácido acético
aunque hay entonces aquí el protón ácido
es este y bueno uno puede ver que el
valor pecado para el ácido acético es de
4.75 aproximadamente ok entonces vamos a
tratar de explicar esto vamos a dibujar
nuestro
a nuestra base con jugada tenemos este
carbono unido a este carbón unido a este
oxígeno
tendremos este este enlace doble al
oxígeno simplemente estamos
prácticamente calcando la molécula
verdad pero como estamos donando aquí
este protón entonces este enlace va a
pasar a ser dos electrones alrededor del
oxígeno verdad tenemos estos dos
electrones alrededor del oxígeno y
completamos con los otros que ya tenían
ahora en el caso anterior también
teníamos un oxígeno verdad en donde se
tenía la carga negativa en este caso
también vamos a tener una carga negativa
en el oxígeno entonces seguramente debe
haber oops seguramente debe existir una
una
seguramente debe existir una estructura
resonante para darle más acidez a esta
estructura entonces vamos a buscar una y
esa por ejemplo sería si este enlace
pasa a hacer dos electrones en este
oxígeno y estos dos datos perdón los
electrones pasan a ser parte de un nuevo
enlace entre este carbono y el oxígeno
entonces cuál sería la estructura
resonante que obtenemos tendríamos este
mismo carbono unido a sus tres perdón
tres hidrógenos que está unido a este
carbono ahora tendríamos un único enlace
a este oxígeno tendríamos estos
electrones y ahora este enlace pasaría a
ser dos electrones alrededor del oxígeno
que es lo que nos queda
qué es lo que nos queda simplemente
pintar este enlace con el oxígeno que
teníamos abajo
ponerlo acá y ahora sólo tenemos dos
pares de electrones y un nuevo enlace un
nuevo enlace entonces como puedes darte
cuenta tuvimos una estructura
en resonante más y nuevamente la
estructura de la base conjugada es un
híbrido de estas dos estructuras
resonantes pero pero esta vez tenemos la
carga negativa deslocalizará y aquí
déjenme pintar la carga negativa que se
encuentra acá aquí la carga negativa se
encuentra deslocalizada y de hecho esto
es lo que le da estabilidad a la base
con jugada pero ésta deslocalizada sobre
dos oxígenos en este caso y eso hace que
la base con jugada sea un aún más ex
perdón más estable que el caso anterior
verdad teniendo la carga negativa
deslocalizada sobre dos oxígenos en este
ejemplo verdad y en el anterior sólo
teníamos una carga negativa en un único
y oxígeno justamente este de aquí
entonces este hecho es lo que el equipo
es bueno el hecho de que se encuentre
deslocalizada la carga negativa en
átomos electro negativos hace que este
guión sea más estable que el anterior y
dado que el anterior es
perdón dado que este es más estable que
la anterior eso significa que el ácido
el ácido acético será más ácido que el
etanol aunque dice que suena como un
poco raro este juego de palabras pero
bueno la idea es esa que la estabilidad
de la estructura de la base conjugada
nos da una mayor acidez y mientras más
estructuras de resonancia podamos
dibujar más estable será la base con
jugada